juste une minute on va pas vous retardez
vous avez rendez-vous de rabiot techno
du tout va bien on va vous poser une
question
je venais avec justesse et comme ça ça
va attendait le monsieur va bien vous
verrez peut-être des sourcils si vous
pouvez les réduire un peu comme ça il y
aurait lui d'en face et pousser pour
vous pour les chaussées parfait alors
vous êtes vous c'est ce que ses gardes
et a profité génique pour parfaire le
triple menton douala alors j'y vais je
vous explique
est ce que vous êtes au courant de la
loi qui vient de passer au à bruxelles
la cour européenne
le 13 avril non non comme le dur et je
vais vous dire sans doute oui je dirais
bien sûr bien sûr les homosexuels
européen - qui vivent en concubinage
vont avoir les mêmes droits que les
homosexuels que les hétérosexuels qui
n'ont concubinage oui c'est à dire ah
bah tu manges les impôts et donc je vous
prie de 1375 fort quand l'un d'entre eux
travaillent porte
mais pour en bénéficier il faut faire
état de son tour du binage permis voilà
c'est à dire je vous explique romain je
suis ce qu'on appelle donc
sexuelle repenti j'étais homosexuel je
suis aujourd'hui hétérosexuels mais j'ai
donc une homosexualité refoulée et donc
moi j'ai aussi eu un formulaire j'ai
cherché à la mairie donc on me demande
avec un témoignage vidéo est également
une attestation
disons que je donc je vis avec un homme
donc je vous demande juste puisque vous
avez dit que vous étiez solidaire je
crois que limite quand même voilà
évidemment maintenant quelqu'un qui met
donc je vous demandais juste
votre nom de dieu non je ne donnerai pas
il s'agit juste de faire état de
de concubinage avec moi donc c'est à
dire va pas mentir c'est moi qui viens
mentir d'accord alors la cassette vidéo
va recevoir la mairie va se faire office
de preuve donc vous vous dites marion
d'accord avec dutournier votre prénom
je vous dirai comment je faisais plaisir
à suivre mais voilà donc je m'appelle
c'est comique sur y d'accord c'est comme
celà x ou y voilà d'accord donc comme
vous l'avez demandé à la mairie
je vous présente mon concubin gérard tu
attends beaucoup d'imagés dans votre jeu
c'est de m'amuser
ça va me permettre de récupérer quand
même eu 3 500 par mois on n'a peut-être
pas besoin vous mais moi oui je suis
comme vous me l'avez demandé à la mairie
je vous présente donc je gerra avec qui
je vis depuis cinq ans dans mes goûts
démissionnant ressentez vous m'avez dit
vous m'avez dit vous même que vous étiez
prêts à aider les gens qui non monsieur
non pas dépendants d'eux mais là je ne
veux pas ce genre de plaisanterie nous
sommes excusés vous on peut reformuler
bon comme vous me l'avez demandé à la
mairie je vous présente mon ex qu'aucune
nation monsieur non attendez mais non
mais non mais attendez nous fait la tête
je vous fais pas la tête à ce que vous
faites parce que ce que vous avez comme
mission de revoir monsieur je vous ai
donc présenté gérard bon écoutez
monsieur ça suffit maintenant dans la
tombola je ne m'appelle pas gérard et
rockit plaisanteries sont peut-être très
bien je dis oui monsieur je m'en fiche
j'ai perdu mon nom était jeudi pour
votre histoire de dire mon ex concubin
dont je veux maintenant je suis pas
d'accord du tout gérard s'en va pas
s'excuser sur votre valise
oui oui vous faites comme si vous partez
toujours monsieur je fais je fais la
vérité parce que vous commencez à quand
un monsieur comme la mairie n'a demandé
[Musique]